bonsoir le 78 en direct entre 18 et 19h
1h pour faire le point sur l'actualité
locale l'actualité du département des
invités comme chaque soir vont nous
accompagner au cours de cette heure au
cours de cette édition du 7 novembre à
commencé par deux des meilleurs ouvriers
de France récompensés hier à Versailles
bonsoir à Véronique abre bonsoir à vous
peintre sur porcelaine et Christophe
Atton vous êtes cuisinier félicitations
à tous les deux on va parler de vos
activités dans quelques instants le
temps d'accueillir également Joanna
souri bonsoir nous sommes mercredi
mercredi le jour de la chronique culture
avec vous dans une quinzaine de minutes
on parlera musique et festival avec deux
festivals feste ivernal qui se déroule à
voisin et à la verrière ce weekend et
puis un autre Festival festival Blues
sur scène voilà qui se déroule tout le
mois de novembre pratiquement Ré ou
blues voilà il faudra choisir d'ici une
quinzaine de minutes tout à l'heure
Johanna on passe à présent au titre les
sujets les reportages à découvrir au
cours de cette édition une manifestation
plutôt originale dans les rue de
Versailles l'association s'appelle L214
elle milite contre la vente de issu de
poules élevé en batterie l'association a
déjà collecté 25000 signatures un
concours difficile qui se prépare en 3
ans et un titre prestigieux celui de MOF
autrement dit meilleur ouvrier de France
dans les ivelines ils sont 7p lauréa
deux d'entre eux sont donc en plateau
avec a nous ce soir Christophe Aton
cuisinier et puis Véronique abrigre que
vous voyez sur ces images cette dernière
a reçu le titre de Meilleur Ouvrier de
France pour son activité de peintre sur
porcelaine un travail délicat et très
prenant et puis les hip hop Games dans
le cadre du projet pulsation urbaine en
atelier qui s'est déroulé à manilamo en
attendant une grande manifestation le 17
novembre à Guille en cours vous y avez
peut-être assisté ce matin à la
manifestation à Versailles devant un
supermarché d'un collectif qui demande
la fin de la commercialisation des œufs
de de des œufs élevés de poules pardon
issus de poules élevé en batterie le
point sur leur revendication ce sera
plus clair avec Anthony R et Patrick
Jacques de dixm ils n'était pas nombreux
ce mercredi devant l'enseigne Monoprix
de Versailles pourtant depuis 1 an ces
militants de l'association L214
manifeste pour inciter le groupe à ne
plus vendre d'œuf de poule élevé en cage
selon eux leurs conditions de vie sont
indigne le groupe milite pour un élevage
uniquement au sol ou en plein air un
fonctionnement déjà adopté en Allemagne
ou en belque alors qu'en France 80 % des
poules sont élevé en batterie c'est pas
juste une volonté d'une association de
protection animale isolée mais que leur
clientèle est d'accord avec cette
démarche refuse elle aussi les ufs de
poule élevés en cage je trouve que ce
sont des conditions ignobles de vie pour
les pou et que vraiment dans une société
évoluée on devrait on devrait pas
accepter ce type de production du tout
enfin c'est vraiment le minimum qu'on
pourrait accorder aux animaux quoi la
pétition lancée par l'association L214 a
déjà réuni plus de 25000 signatures
suite à des discussions avec
l'association l'enseigne Monoprix a
réagi en retirant de ses rayon les œufs
de poule élevés en cage de sa marque
distributeur dans une trentaine de
magasins de la région lyonnaise une
évolution sous forme de test qui se
terminera un petit peu responsable
l'autre information du jour dans les
ivelines c'est cet arrêt de l'équipe
nocturne qui travaille sur la 208 à
poissi Peugeot subit la crise et devant
un marché européen au point mort a
décidé qu'à compter du 3 décembre il n'y
aurait plus de travail de nuit dans son
usine sur ce modèle le nombre
d'intérimaires va également être réduit
passer de 1400 à cet été dernier à 150
en janvier du côté des syndicats on
regrette notamment de voir la production
de la 208 partir en Slovaquie nous
allons parler à présent donc des
meilleurs ouvriers de France ils ont été
récompensés hier à Versailles dans les
ivelines